given your expertise and chip design and
manufacturing and the work that you're
doing SBI mind chip how does the having
play out here for miners like any
thoughts on on kind of that Bitcoin
having in the effect on miners and I'm
not gonna you know be so arrogant just
tell you that I know what's going to
happen because I don't what I will tell
you is just you know we look at the
historical data we expect that a lot of
the miners operating in farms where the
electricity prices were above around six
cents per kilowatt-hour all in kind of
costs right are gonna be profitable
anyway right so these all those and so
you expect the total that we have to
typically go down afterwards right and
you also expect mining orders to go down
because there's a psychology to this
whole thing
it's like I'm a mining rewards less well
that doesn't see what you go into
anymore no ironically right well one of
the first things I learned in mining is
that the mighty reward size and the help
doesn't really it doesn't even make
sense when I say because the revenues go
down right but the idea is that because
it takes out a lot of the harm
what happens is it's a winner-take-all
kind of a situation the whole way to win
in mining is to have the lowest
electricity cost the highest power most
power efficient miners so that when the
helgenaes happen or when the price of
Bitcoin goes down you can still be
profitable or at least break even while
everyone else or a lot of their others
have to shut down because literally
every second they operate they're losing
more money right and then if you can
hang on the total that where cash rate
goes down because and then the
difficulty goes down and then your
percentage of blocks that you might goes
up and you can actually make even more
money than before the healthy
potentially if enough people get out so
that's why the strategy is that's
hardware right and then there's all this
competition to go find you how and you
know what
first got into it you hear oh you know
it's this Kazakhstan earth this stand
right or it's this you know new thing in
Africa right and these like
geopolitically unstable areas okay what
is Chi power you know we're the biggest
source of cheap power actually turned
out to be in the world right in the
United States in argue arguably true
right you know one of the most
geopolitically stable places like the
power not going out right but anyway and
so there's a lot going on in places like
Texas in New York State upstate from
where you are
Pacific Northwest as well turns out
there's a hell of a lot of excess energy
in America and you know it's just not
that the marketplace was really not
there to connect some of these mining
companies in the mining industry so
after the happening I expect the network
and I also though I feel there's a huge
psychology aspect to it people hate to
show off miners especially if they just
wanna because they feel like they
screwed up and so they often hang on
longer than they should and they just
increase the size of the crater they're
creating for themselves
so you see lagging indicator on that too
but eventually you know they can't do it
and it's just like I buy like Apple
stock alright
it goes down what does every person want
to do they're not gonna sell until it
goes back up you know cuz I don't want
to feel like I was an idiot right but
you know what's right things right as
soon as it goes down you get rid of that
dog and then you invest it in something
that has a higher likelihood of going up
based on you know research do
unfortunately though you know we can't
change and how long humans think so
you'll see a lagging indicator on the on
the network a stream basically what I'm
saying then you'll start a a recycle
refresh base where people will go and
have raised capital to replace all those
little miners if they had cheap enough
power but they didn't have enough power
the close up shop and that's okay that's
part of how you know such other she sort
of designed this thing because those
miners that are going to operate half
the mine more blocks they're going to
run a business
same-sized are bigger than they had
before the house because the mining
reward did come and then ultimately
we'll see this transition to fees going
up right so that that natural balance
between mining companies getting revenue
from transaction fees grows as the you
know mining reward revenue kind of
continues to go down through subsequent
happenings